welcome back some new rock stars I'm
Erik Bosse in the mandalorian chapter
three the sin continues this hot streak
of solid straightforward Western
inspired Star Wars storytelling that has
this looking of our shoulder thing and
yeah this is actually good right I'm
enjoying a Star Wars thing without
complaint cool just making sure of the
three episodes so far this one might
contain some of the deepest cut Star
Wars Easter eggs yet and in addition to
that some really clever visual details
that show how much craft has been put
into these episodes so let's break it
all down spoilers ahead this episode
opens with the adorable moment on mando
ship with baby Yoda unscrewing a knob
off a lever because babies will toys I
know I know I really should be calling
them something like Yoda Ling because
baby Yoda implies he's Yoda's baby or
Yoda's clone something that's not
confirmed yet but yodeling both the word
itself and the sound if it's my head
stupid so deal with it until he's named
he's baby Yoda cool they return to the
residents of the client greeted once
again by the gatekeeper droid we saw one
of these at Jabba's palace and Return of
the Jedi this episode often places the
camera inside the babies pod with him in
my breakdown at chapter 2 I pointed out
the parallel between baby Yoda encased
in the pod and mando encased in his
helmet these protective shells that
limit their views of the outside world
mando hands off baby Yoda to the client
in dr. Pershing and Pershing's red
scanner light reflects on mandos helmet
as if he too is undergoing a kind of
identity verification in this moment
what kind of man is he is the bounty
worth giving up this innocent child the
container that the client stores the
best car inside is an awesome Easter Egg
this prop is from the Empire Strikes
Back it's carried by a random Cloud City
resident named will ro hood as people
fled the city the prop is made from an
ice cream maker so fans over the years
have loved this and called him ice cream
guy and during production in the
mandalorian Jon Favreau's shared an
Instagram post of it is love that hadn't
have planed a pretty big role here her
song opened it the client is insulted
when mando asks what they're gonna do
with the kid pointing out that asking
about the fate of the bounty is against
guild code this episode as a whole is
very much about codes ways customs
before it was quill who would repeat his
mantra I
now the Mandalorians repeat this is the
way now this episode's title is the sin
suggests it's a sin to violate such ways
and means but we learn at the end of the
episode that there's actually a greater
sin that one could carry on one's
conscience the sin of inaction the sin
of letting evil go forward mando is
challenged by this heavy infantry guy
credited in other places as past Vizsla
and I'm pretty sure this is voiced by
Jon Favreau himself make a little kindly
now our strength was once in our numbers
this Mandalorian is proud angry over
having to live like sand rats and
secrecy making deals with the devil to
maintain their way of life and when they
fight you notice how their daggers
vibrates these aren't vibro blades off
to mention weapons and the Star Wars
University if a current that maximizes
cutting effectiveness mando tells the
armour about the mud horn I guess I was
its name makes sense that he defeated
last episode but since it was assisted
by baby Yoda he refuses to make it his
signet so we learned that to the
Mandalorian cygnets come from a beast
that you have to kill or tame this
actually stems from their ancestor
Mandalore the first who first conquered
the great mythos are of their planets
that's why the leaders of the
Mandalorians bear as their signet the
skull of the mythos or the armor are
forges for him whistling birds guided
bullets similar to yondu's Yakka arrow
and the guardians the galaxy movies
which he does command via whistling and
once again during the Scourge montage
mando is triggered back to memories of
his family under attack we see in this
memory that the attackers are super
battle droids these were used by the
separatists during the Clone Wars so
here's my question
if the separatist droid is the one that
attacked mando and his family leaving
him with a lifelong hatred of droids who
do we think rescued him here is it a
clone trooper or someone we might know
like Anakin Skywalker general Kenobi
hello that war could his rescuer have
been the great Yoda explaining his
fondness for this young creature let me
know who you think saved him in the
comments below before I continue thank
you to expressvpn for sponsoring this
episode a VPN allows you to browse the
internet with privacy without things
like ad companies hackers spyware
any of these shady types tracking your
data secretly filtering your Internet
experience expressvpn masks your IP
address to make sure you aren't being
monitored so you can have that peace of
mind you can live life knowing and pire
like Verner Hertzog aren't tracking your
movement and sending bounty hunters
after you personally I use expressvpn
recently when I was out of us and I
wasn't able to stream who episodes of
Rick and Morty but use the in expressvpn
now no one could filter what I want to
watch online just based on where I am or
what they decide I should have access to
expressvpn is the fastest VPN on the
market and the number one VPN service
rated by TechRadar I'd say in a
different country you might not be able
to get access to everything on Netflix
for YouTube or other streaming services
thanks to express VPN you can avoid
those weird restrictions and just watch
everything you would want to normally
the way the Internet should be wherever
you happen to be that moment expressvpn
lets you securely stream or download
content from anywhere at any time it's
less than $7 a month with a 30-day
money-back guarantee and you can get
three extra months free by clicking on
the link in the description visit
expressvpn dot-com slash new rock stars
moving on mando returns to his guild
leader reef carga he has been paid well
in bests car to something that gives
mando pause because in his eyes every
piece of best car is a stolen natural
resource from his homeworld that belongs
to his people so later shooting him in
that piece of metal seem like kind of a
stinging reminder of that mandos next
target is a blonde calamari whom grief
describes as a nobleman's son perhaps
that nobleman could be the war hero
admiral ackbar though it's a little
racist to assume all Mon Calamari are
related Reeves says that the Bounty
Hunter is on the ocean dunes of Karnak
Karnak could have gotten its name from
the Karnak temple ruins of Egypt
I appreciated Amanda's discs of the New
Republic joke it's a sobering reminder
that despite the apparent universe wide
celebration after the Battle of Endor
the efforts to restore democracy from
the ashes of the Empire are fledgling at
best and barely a generation later it's
all gonna be replaced by an empire
doppelganger back on his ship mando fine
for the knob and he freezes can you just
gotta love a hero moment when the
seemingly heartless guy goes still as he
works at the nerve to go back and do the
right thing and now notice mandos helmet
reflects a green light a contrast with
the red light from a poor grain being
the color of Jedi lightsabers red the
color of Sith lightsabers red meaning
stop this and green now signaling go get
up or go ahead and stop and go ahead and
leave green means go so I know to go
ahead and shut up about it
as he marches back into danger the
composer once the
again sneaks in a light motif to John
Williams force theme
mando spots the discarded pod in the
garbage
I pointed out before how that pod was
designed to evoke the shape of an egg
and now seeing this empty eggshell in
the trash reminds mando of how his
previous clients handled that egg
bounties greeted again by the gatekeeper
droid man who rips off its head just
like how baby Yoda removed the knob from
the end of that lever inside mando finds
per Sheen with baby Yoda and a classic
IT Oh Imperial interrogator droid just
like the one Vader used on Leia on the
Death Star now it's not clear what
procedure he was doing but his patch
does look like the same emblem of the
Kamino cloning facility and attack of
the clones so perhaps the aim is to
attempt to clone this newly discovered
member of Yoda species rather than this
child being a clone of anything itself
because think about it the client
wouldn't have cared if this kid died
because all he needs is his DNA and
maybe that interrogator droid was here
to supervise pershing mando escapes of
the kid and the other bounty hunters get
notified kind of like that moment in
John wick too when all the other
assassins getting notified to go after
him grief drops another classic Star
Wars not because I'm your only hope
mando escapes by taking cover in an
astromech droid driven carriage that he
passed earlier forcing him to finally be
escorted in a vehicle driven by an
astromech droid go droids gets bailed
out by the other Mandalorians on
jetpacks including Paz vizla who later
soars behind it gives him a salute which
with this being Pedro has got to be an
Ironman shoutout right an coming full
circle with the opening scene baby Oda
finally gets his ball and it feels
closely you can hear he lets up its tiny
little giggle finding us at the moment
that we first met one of these things
back on Dagobah
similarly laughing it up as he played
with the stuff that he shouldn't be
playing with Tom and Mo with your
thoughts on this episode follow me on
instagram or twitter at ETA vas to
subscribe to our WikiLeaks podcast feed
for all of our Star Wars analysis thanks
for joining me
[Music]